hi everyone so this is definition here
with my Arkham Knight playthrough if
you've been checking out my other
playthroughs you know that I'm a bit a
bit of a Batman expert I've got a
website definition car at UK where I'm
currently reading through all the can
illogical Batman graphic novels ranking
them from best to worst and I'm also on
the side of that plane through Arkham
Asylum
Arkham City are now Arkham Knight and
kind of showing what graphic novels
influenced certain parts of the game the
other games are kind of played through
just the first two hours or whatever
this I'm gonna kind of break it up into
chunks Arkham Knights like a massively
underrated game I think I think
Arkham City was so successful that
people just thought alright well
everything from now one's gonna be at
this level and unfortunately Rocksteady
did overdo the Batmobile quite a bit I
know that was massively hyped up before
and it was a bit of a boy's
disappointment like they give it too
much and this opener is absolutely
brilliant
so it's following on pretty much
directly from the end of Arkham City and
lets you know straight away the Joker is
dead he's not coming back he's
definitely dead he's cremated you've
just done it and I just saw that it was
a really creative way to open and
fortunately III rocksteady for some
reason spoiled the the Scarecrow opener
which is we're just about going to now
which if you didn't know in advance I
think this would be a massive like
surprise er
and it's just a shame that they they
kind of introduced her like this so
you've got Commissioner Gordon talking
that same voices the guy who played Mike
in Breaking Bad is his name kind of
skips my head at the moment but
he's a really good fit for Commissioner
Gordon I think if they ever cast him in
a film he'd also be a really good fit
obviously my main man JK Simmons AKA j
jonah Jameson
he's Commissioner Gordon now but I think
I think this Mike guy would have done a
great job so it's it's good I would just
start you've got Sefton Hill there on
the right just walk out the diner he's
the game's director so he's had a cameo
in all the games and that is one there
and you've got the the diner here I just
remember this like playing through this
and thinking oh you've got like a TV
it's got Arkham City on it there with
the courthouse the to face one paulie's
diner there and named after Paul Dini
who wrote the script for Arkham Asylum
and Arkham City so it's nice that they
kind of homage him a bit there with
without gotten the controls here it's
nice to him watched him a bit with them
just calling the paulie's dynamic so
it's it's really good how it just starts
off you've got Henry Adams there who
comes a new Alea quite in quite a big
way and it's quite a little dull
beginning it's obviously you know near
Halloween you've got a scarecrow mask
they've got a guy in a Batman mask and
then you've got a guy coming over here
he's seen something strange in the
corner
so this kind of I think takes
inspiration directly from a god of fear
story and it takes part during the night
for lark and it's it's featured in
shadow of the bat and that's the run
it's from and it basically involves the
Scarecrow sort of poisoning Gotham it's
more kind of him going after citizens
and this is sort of the whole threat
that the game takes on you've got such a
good opener here and I'm very lucky to
have a 4k TV you know I don't want to
brag yeah but if it's in there fifty
inches you know you know I know
good TV when I see it and just see in
this scene play out it still looks
absolutely fantastic and the way it
transitions from from the start it's
just really good and I love how kind of
it changes this genre of a bit like
first-person shooters are obviously a
massive game genre and it's good to see
you know they're doing this no no so
like this is what the Scarecrow it's the
best way to introduce the threat of the
Scarecrow like you see people how they
act I also do think this takes
inspiration directly from Sandman which
is written by Neil Gaiman it's a really
really good graphic novel if you get a
chance to do that you've got there
Johnny charisma there and getting
borderline and scarecrow they obviously
is suffering from the wounds that he got
in Arkham Asylum when Killer Croc tore
tore off his face off anyway back to
what I was saying so Sandman knits an
arc in that that takes part in a diner
where a villain goes in who can
basically control human emotion and you
can make everyone really happy so at one
point all the members in the diner start
having sex with each other but it can
also make their emotions really depraved
and it gets to a point where they stop
murdering each other and it all takes
place over the space of about 24 hours I
think and it's just a really good
adventure through human emotions and the
different contrasts that and duplicity
that we all share within us so I do
think that opener takes inspiration from
that you've got the the policeman
getting shot there and this is also a
brilliant way to kind of introduce just
you know a cop gets shot and by penguin
and two-face obviously you can see the
graphical upgrade
that was made when they moved to the ps4
and it's just great how Arkham is in
complete anarchy it sort of reminds me a
lot of no man's land and Cataclysm
contagion as well which are all huge
also the cult and which are all huge
stories in which you know the the
villains the criminals take over Gotham
City and it's great seeing this on a
surface level and then the camera pans
up directly to Batman and it's all in
one shot and you can see that just the
skylines absolutely incredible and
you've got the bat-signal there and you
know just to see Batman up on this perch
it's a perfect way to introduce the
character and you know what as good as
the arkham city in reduction is i think
this is probably the best out of all
three and for beginning the game you've
got the excellent joke confirmation that
he's dead and then you you've got the
diner and then you start off here and
you just glide off and you're
immediately in the game and there's no
tutorial or anything it's just sort of
like yeah up there above everyone you
can see the blimps which are often a big
part of Arkham so you got them like if
you ever watched the animated series
from 1992 the the blimps are just a huge
huge part of that game and you've got
you've got Batman sneaking up on
Commissioner Gordon and I love how it's
something that's became a motif of
Batman is when he disappears
mid-sentence as Commissioner Gordon saw
Burton it's good that they they get the
chance to do that in this game because I
wasn't there in Arkham City and it
wasn't there and Arkham Asylum and it's
it's funny how in the Justice League
trailer that the new one they're making
a joke out of it and with the flash
standing back and be like that's a bit
rude that they may
disappeared so really great old men and
this is still the best rain I've ever
seen in a game like it's amazing how it
just relies on the characters so anyway
back to the coaling involves Deacon
Frost who actually features in this game
he brainwashes Batman he breaks them
down by basically starving them not
torturing him but tying them up and it
was you know just like using just
mind-control techniques to eventually
get him to join his forces and the city
just goes a Miss Serena the city just
goes to hell
homeless people end up right in and then
taking over the entire city and Batman
really gets broken down and he's got a
gold back to the Batcave recover get
Robin and they ride into Gotham in a
monster truck Batmobile and take down
Deacon for us and it just I just love
whenever Gotham gets taken over like it
happens and a lot in the new 52 and
you've got Riddler does it in zero yeah
which he blacks out the city and says
every day right I'll let control of the
city go back to the regular people but
you still have to answer a riddle and if
you do then I'll give you control that
of course it's the red left so the
riddles are you know the there's a trick
to them and pretty much everyone gets
fed to the Lions and you can see the
combats being upgraded here and it's
just so much more fluid you're able to
take on much bigger groups of people in
a more free flow manner and I just
remember playing it and getting a
massive buzz off it especially when you
can pick up the bat and stuff you've got
the blimps there which I'm just gliding
pass which are a huge homage another
blimp sorry the balloons
very clearly referenced in the Batman 89
movie in which of course the joke leads
a parade through the Gotham City Center
and he has his whole balloons and Batman
just comes in on the batwing and we get
the famous line I don't know you know I
don't think no where does he get those
wonderful toys from it is that part of
the movie but yeah it's just an
absolutely brilliant scene in which
Batman just takes all of the balloons
out and we've got coming up here one of
the best introductions to the Batmobile
ever
he just gets a lot out there and it's
nice how they kind of upgraded the
Arkham City suit like very subtly and
just yet this is one of the best yeah
there's a you know playing through like
analytically and going through the
beginnings of every game in the series
yeah this is by far the best
introduction like just the amount of
detail that they put into this and that
the ps4 can deliver is absolutely crazy
like you can zoom in very close to
characters and there's immense detail on
them and then pull out in this there's
still a detail for the city and just
getting to drive the Batmobile it's a
big thing and I do wish there were more
sections like this and instead of just
like stealth tank Batmobile like I
remember when you had to do that stealth
tank bits and I was thinking just the
word stealth and tank should never be
used in the same sense ever
and it was great how you could upgrade
the battery skin the Batmobile and you
know the 89 versions my favorite one
developed by Anton Furst who sadly
committed suicide after the the initial
Batman film release it was just a
brilliant looking car and I really just
it's one of the best movie cars of all
time I think there are these lads I
think they're gonna I think they're
gonna be
so it's kind of hard to talk about the
main inspirations this early on in the
game if you've ever read the under the
Red Hood of that obviously plays a
massive spoiler into the and the end of
the game which it's a shame that they
they decided to steal the twist
completely from that especially after
hyping it up for ages that they were
going to be developing a brand new
character and which was a load of Sh in
it didn't make sense like someone who
masking themselves to be another person
in a mask and yeah it was I think that's
another reason why people got so annoyed
with Arkham Knight which is a shame
because they had had just made the the
Arkham Knight in this the character that
he turns out to be if they're just made
him that from the start that would have
been a it really would have been like a
really good game and people wouldn't
have been disappointed with the twist
Oracle and Barbara Gordon who is
famously paralyzed by the Joker in the
story The Killing Joke absolutely
stellar story like when I first read I
didn't really like it because I think
they'd been hyped up so much but it's
it's so twisted and I love the joke at
the end which is something like there's
two people in an insane asylum they're
trying to escape one guy goes to walk
across a beam jumps across one jumps
across the roof to escape and get the
torch out and shines it across and says
you know you can jump across just walk
over the beam and the other and the same
guy goes no I'll not do that he'll just
turn it off when I'm halfway across and
it kind of speaks to metaphorically the
madness of the The Joker and Batman
which character it meant to be rich in
that joke the whole story is about this
joke and it really surmises Batman and
the Joker's relationship and the whole
story is about Batman trying to be like
look we are gonna kill each other
eventually I don't want that if if there
is a way to become you know to just be
civil then I'll happily take it
unfortunate man doesn't get to deliver
that speech to Joker as he's escaped I
mean the joke at the end just perfectly
sums up their relationship Batman wants
to with all his heart just stop the
madness that the Joker's brought forward
but I think when he hears that joke he
just realizes that there's no hope and I
don't care what anyone says
Batman kills the Joker in The Killing
Joke and I'm kind of wondering if the
DCR gonna pick up on this again in
rebirth because I know that there
they've introduced three Joker's which
they've done and they've just completely
dropped the ball with and not mentioned
again so it will be interesting to see
how how it goes with that but I think
personally that one of the Joker's was
the one in The Killing Joke and they
were murdered and Tom King at the
moments do I never know if it's Tom King
or Tom Kane you know and it's really bad
and he's currently doing the war of
jokes in riddles and in which the joke
is just stop finding things funny so
he's almost going to a next level to try
and find a joke that that's gonna make
him laugh and he and he realizes that
riddles are similar to jokes and so he
meets up with the Riddler but any
betrays them and shoot some Batman shows
up and realizes you know the the Joker's
the RIP sorry the Riddler's fatally
wounded here
I can chase after the Joker and probably
catch him or I can take the Riddler to
the hospital
and Batman very unlike Batman decides
that as the Riddler's gonna die he's
just gonna go after the Joker and leave
them there
the Riddler doesn't die and it starts a
massive war across the city in which the
Riddler wants to kill the Joker and vice
versa and the the entire cities just
kind of just a warzone we've just seen
there that poison ivy talks about how
toxins don't have an effect on now which
is a big part of the character there's a
story called Batman contagion which I'm
briefly mentioned earlier in which the
apocalypse virus which is also known as
the clench gets unleashed in Gotham and
it's a form of Ebola a which just kills
people within 48 hours and poison ivy
basically is tasked by Batman to take
the take the cure a certain people
because he knows she's the only person
that can survive these this toxin this
is a brilliant bit so you get your
Batmobile out here it's brilliant how
you can just call it in by remote
control
anyway Batman sends the Adam sends
poison ivy you know one of the ways the
most duplicitous villains that he's got
in to deliver the cure these rich people
unfortunately being the evil woman that
she is she she had betrayed them and
decides to to sell the The Cure to the
highest bidder because the people who
blocked themselves in this tower or some
of the wealthiest in Gotham and it is
just yeah it's really good that Batman
then has to he's realized what's gonna
happen so he has to break into the tower
and take down poison ivy it's sort of a
bit like die hard it's not like as as
big as die hard but it's still it's
still a really good story now one
hundred percent recommend picking up
Cataclysm it's not you know amazing but
it leads into legacy and then it leads
directly in a road to no-man's land
which of course leads directly in a
no-man's land
and which are all absolutely stellar
stories so you sort of need that one to
to almost set there the grounds for the
story can be built upon it involves Tim
Drake getting the virus and when they
find that find out after thinking that
they've cured it that the virus mutates
and through the legacy storyline and
becomes the legacy virus and everyone
who who was cured now gets a deadlier
version of it and it's just it's just
really intense
Dick Grayson used to be my favorite
Robin but I think after reading
nightfall contagion legacy and Tim Drake
just just became my favorite by far I
mean he's got the he's got the well I've
got to do this one as well yeah
unfortunately the game sort of takes a
not a massive dive but you know it's a
lot of tutorials that
mind so Tim Drake he's not as much of a
[ __ ] as Jason Todd which makes him
better and he's as cunning as degrade
him but he's also a detective like in
death of the family he figured out that
Dick Grayson and Batman were Batman
so he found it figured out decorating in
Bruce Wayne were Batman and Robin it's a
very hard to talk when you you're trying
to shoot stupid tanks tank fighting
likes tank fights not me so he had years
there really the one of the best
all-rounders and decorate and even goes
on have become Batman beyond that
unfortunately has been rewritten but it
was very good and played out in features
end which is the story about the Batman
of the future traveling back in time to
when brother I was created because in
the future it's an AI that has taken
over the basically the world and
destroyed it being it's sort of like
DC's Days of Future past and it involves
all the earth two heroes and it's a very
sort of
yeah I'm an idiot like I could have
could have just done that straightaway
so yeah these tanks section site there
just just overdid them so much really
looking back like anything that sort of
like the Batmobile in this game is just
tethered to you and there is one bit
where it gets destroyed and when it got
destroyed I was just like thank [ __ ] for
that unfortunately about 10 minutes
later you get it back and once when I
seen it come back I was like aha
yes yes it's back I then realised yeah
I'm never getting rid of this thing it's
gonna be here forever so that was nice
it's just a bloody shame because they
had they didn't really neat you've had
the game out it was long enough without
it and unfortunately out of the Riddler
challenges involve it so you if you want
to complete them you've got to do it I
do think it is a cool looking Batmobile
I was originally gonna get the statue
but just
that's good so yeah like I could have
just cooked down so much of this [ __ ]
haven't always just fight in the
Batmobile
you got Dixon duck yeah the great girls
poster there it's a tribute to Adam West
rest in peace who sadly passed away
recently so in the animated series
Batman as a kid used to watch TV show
called the Gray Ghost which was voiced
by Adam West which you know it's
obviously a homage to the 1966 show and
he sort of was inspired by this you know
this this fighter who used to go this
vigilante basically used to go and solve
crimes it was a really nice way to
homage the first season and also like
merge the two together like this was
before cameos are a massive thing and
then Batman through the episode realizes
that a criminals perpetrating a lot of
crimes that were on the TV show about
the Gray Ghost so he goes down finds
where the Gray Ghost is the actor and
they both go out together to solve these
crimes and it's a nice little tie tie-in
of how you know yeah you meet me you
should meet your heroes it reminds me of
my dream when I met Christian Bale it
was the best
so the clock tower is Barbara Gordon's
base and it was also used almost as a
Batcave in the aftermath of Batman r.i.p
in which Batman so he gets killed in
Final Crisis and dick Dick Grayson
realizes that you know Gotham needs a
Batman so he takes over the role in and
there's a big war for it in the book
called battle for the cowl in which
Jason Todd comes back and he wants and
there's a couple people who who want the
role eventually Dick Grayson takes on
the manhole and and obviously dick was
always sort of a Batman's very broody
moody guy
whereas Dick Grayson is and he's quite
happy um so he sort of it inverts
everything Batman is and Joker even
comments on it like you fight more like
a bird than a bat and even it everything
down to its base is a tower and it's
just it's just a nice little twist on
the character of course we know Bruce
Wayne comes back eventually
but it's good that he can leave the the
manhole in the safe hands of Dick
Grayson because there was a point where
he couldn't and he initially gave it to
Sean Paul Valley who let's get it then
it's good how you could go on the
evidence Locker and get your old
equipment out early like that but a lot
of people didn't know and I didn't
realize in the bat-cave it was like
grenades and stuff that you could pick
up
I'm so so in the nightfall saga Batman
gives the role to John Paul Valley after
his back gets broken by Bane jump or
Valley mental lad and goes around
murdering people killing them so Bruce
is basically like you know what this
probably isn't a good idea and he need
to not have someone in place who's an
idiot so he gives it to Dick Grayson in
the story prodigal Prudential prodigal
or whatever it's called anyway they'll
add there's a bloody stellar job a bit
so he gets to he gets you know left is
substitute number two that's a really
good story it sort of deals with a lot
of father and son things obviously a lot
of people don't acknowledge it but you
know Dick Grayson is Bruce Wayne's son
and he adopted him and left him like a
father so it's a really good little
twist on it and it's sort of also deals
with Dick Grayson being angry that
Batman didn't ask him he's like why
didn't you just you know tell people why
do you just tell me that I could do it
instead of giving it a Jean Paul values
mess to sit here and while you can smash
this guy's hand the person should you
know
and so yeah it deals with you know it's
a whole father-and-son thing where
Batman's like well I know you wanted to
be your own man and I didn't want to
hold you back and say oh you have to
follow my footsteps and dicks like well
why didn't you just ask me and it's a
whole breakdown of communication and
there was several years where briefs and
dick didn't really interact because of
how Bruce sort of trained him as a kid
he did great and don't really have a
childhood because he was too busy you
know trying to be Robin and he sort of
saw as like you you took away my
childhood fighting this war that I
didn't want to fight and it's just a
really good little like look character
study and I do wish there were sort of
more things like that which sort of
analyzed like they don't hate each other
but like a lot of father-and-son
relationships that get frayed due to a
lack of communication and so I always
wanted what's best for you son even if I
didn't exactly go about it in the best
way which it's just a really good look
at the character and I know that they
are talking about if they do a sequel to
this game then it might either be with
Damian Wayne or Dick Grayson and it
would be really good to see those
characters in it they also said it might
be a sequel to Arkham origins so we just
have to see but the game's not been
announced yet it's getting done by WB
Montreal who made Arkham origins which
you know some people like that game some
people hate it personally I quite like
it um I think it's definitely got the
best story out of everything
so yeah that's that's my thought on that
one so I'm just upgrading stuff here at
the moment no really I don't really need
it I'm pretty good at this game without
this stuff if you don't mind it's say in
there mate anyway cheers for listenin to
that story so it's basically the way I'm
gonna do this game is I'm gonna play
through the entire thing I'm not going
to like make you watch me play through
the entire thing and but just in key
bits I'm gonna record you know certain
sections so whilst this first part is
just kind of a I'm also open thing there
the next couple parts will be more
selective of what I take so we're going
to Professor Pegg right now and I know
that I've not really read much with
Professor Pig he did feature quite
heavily in the Batman and Robin must die
storyline with once again Dick Grayson
being Batman and Damian Wayne in Robin
and he basically wants to make perfect
people which this murder investigation
sort of centers around and the game does
a really good job of showcasing like
what kind of person he is and if you've
ever get a chance to watch beware the
batman
and what's the only word for one series
it was still really enjoyable and a lot
of it does feature professor pick them
and he's just kind of a he's a complete
psychopath
and I do quite like the character and I
thought use a big goofy at first but
once I've read the grand Morrison
running which he murders people whether
there's just because he's aside it you
do you do kind of realize like he has
got a sinister vibe to him so definitely
try and check out anything check
anything else by Grant Morrison that has
Batman in hand because you'll not be
disappointed if you're gonna pick up
from Batman and son onwards make sure
you read it in order because I read it
in the wrong order like a read Batman
Incorporated first that's all this is
alright but it's not amazing and whereas
once I read it in chronological order
from start to finish I just thought it
was absolutely mind-blowing I there's so
many little touches like there's one
issue like early on where Batman some
prostitutes questions to see you know to
get to the bottom of this investigation
and and was the girl yes the questions -
he says like look you don't need me
doing this blah blah blah I heard
they're hiring at Wayne Enterprises and
then about 7 volumes later you just see
this the girl they don't really
highlight it but she's just working as a
receptionist there and it's just little
touches like that that really make the
book sort of and the run just next-level
like everything ties together all has a
point like Graham Morrison's a great
believer that everything in Batman's and
we like all Batman stories are canon
somehow so the things that happened in
the 30s or Batman when he was a younger
younger guy and the things that happened
in the 50s were Batman when he was you
know in these twenties he met Robin he
it was so come be cuz Robin brightened
up his life in the seventies it started
getting darker again but you know it
wasn't it was in his thirties and then
in the 80s it just went kind of batshit
crazy
I just went Jason died and that's why
everything was so dark and it's just the
guys that really got it all planned out
so definitely pick up that run anyway
that's my playthrough of Arkham Knight
for now I'm probably going to do five
playthroughs on this like I'd originally
only did three on the other games but
there's so much to talk about in this
would be a shame not to so thanks very
much for checking out this please like
and subscribe to my channel check out my
other playthroughs as well are we if we
show that and if you get the chance go
to definition code at UK that's
definition with two EPs and check out my
comic reviews like I said I'm reading
through all of the Batman graphic novels
from start to finish and but more so
covering things like Watchmen I do a
watchman podcast with my good friend Tom
qui and I cover like Suicide Squad
Justice League I just do it all yeah
so check it out and thanks very much for
watching this video thank you take care
you